The story goes like this. Recently I heard about this couple. He's in his 40s. She's in her mid-20s. And the way it was explained to me, they were having this conversation, and it was one of these conversations that, if you've ever been in a couple with a big age difference, maybe you've taken part in, he was saying basically, what can you see in me? You know, you are so young and energetic and I'm this older person. I'm so much more serious.
故事是这样的。最近我听说了一对情侣。男方40多岁，女方20岁出头。据向我解释的情况，他们当时正在进行一场对话，如果你曾经经历过年龄差距很大的恋情，可能也参与过类似的对话。男方基本上是在问：“你到底看上了我哪一点？要知道，你如此年轻充满活力，而我是一个年纪较大的人。我比你严肃得多。”
And they talked about this and talked about this. And finally, she brought the conversation to a stop by declaring, no, no, no, don't you understand? I am Dennis Rodman. You are Phil Jackson. You ground me. I am wild. You make everything all right. And that's the way it is right now in Chicago, where I speak to you from right now. Our historic championship basketball team, the Chicago Bulls, is not just the winningest team of all time, with 72 regular season wins, now hurtling through the NBA playoffs. What's happened here in Chicago is that the Bulls are now the lens through which we view all of our experiences. They're the benchmark against we're measuring everything in our lives. They've become our reality.
他们谈了又谈。最后，她宣称：“不，不，不，你难道不明白吗？我就是丹尼斯·罗德曼，你就是菲尔·杰克逊。你让我脚踏实地。我狂野不羁，而你让一切都变得安好。”这正是此刻芝加哥的情况，也就是我向你们广播的地方。我们历史性的冠军篮球队——芝加哥公牛队，不仅是史上胜率最高的球队，在常规赛中取得72场胜利，现在更是势如破竹地冲向NBA季后赛。芝加哥现在发生的事情是，公牛队已成为我们观察所有经历的视角。他们是我们衡量生活中一切事物的标杆。他们已经成为了我们的现实。
Today, in this hour, a dispatch from a city that has left the rest of the American culture and entered into its own little subculture, a basketball subculture. At nights in Chicago, now the Hancock building, which towers over the city, is lit a bright Bulls-red. Bulls posters and souvenirs and caps and T-shirts are for sale in every video storage and corner drugstore, in bars, everywhere. It's like living in China during the cultural revolution. Slogans and propaganda, everywhere, all uniting us as one people. The name United Center was never more appropriate than now. There we are, united behind the vanguard-- Michael, Scottie, Dennis, Phil, Luke, our vanguard, and all the others.
今天在这一小时里，我们将从这座脱离了美国其他文化，进入自己独特亚文化——篮球亚文化——的城市发出一篇报道。现在的芝加哥，夜晚耸立在城市之上的汉考克中心被照亮成明亮的公牛红。公牛队的海报、纪念品、帽子和T恤在每家音像店、街角药店、酒吧，到处都有销售。这就像生活在中国的文化大革命时期。到处都是口号和宣传，把我们所有人都团结成一个整体。联合中心球馆（United Center）的名字在今天看来再贴切不过了。我们就在那里，团结在先锋队员们的身后——迈克尔、斯科蒂、丹尼斯、菲尔、卢克，以及其他所有人。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, I'm Ira Glass. You're listening to This American Life. And I know actually that many people who have never heard our program before around the country are hearing us for the first time today. So a quick word of explanation, the idea of this radio show is to document what's going on around the country, in these United States, using all the different forms of radio storytelling that we can think of, including documentary, monologues, found tapes, just whatever we can think of. Each week, we choose a theme. And our theme for this hour is basketball-- stories of people who have a basketball jones of one sort or another.
大家好，我是来自WBEZ芝加哥电台的艾拉·格拉斯。你正在收听的是《美国生活》。我知道其实全国各地有很多从未听过我们节目的人今天第一次收听。所以简单解释一下，这个广播节目的主旨是用我们能想到的各种广播叙事形式，包括纪录片、独白、现成录音等，来记录这个国家——美利坚合众国——正在发生的事情。每周我们都会选择一个主题。而我们这一小时的主题是篮球——那些对篮球有着某种痴迷的人们的故事。
Act One of our show today, The Bulls in Our Hearts. Act Two, Bulls in a Barbershop. Act Three, What Basketball Means, stories of people who love the game. Act Four, Basketball and Commerce, in which, among other things, we visit Bulls star Scottie Pippen's car dealership. And Act Five, the greatest moment in radio-- ever. Stay with us.
我们今天节目的第一幕是《心中的公牛队》。第二幕是《理发店里的公牛队》。第三幕是《篮球意味着什么》，讲述那些热爱这项运动的人们的故事。第四幕是《篮球与商业》，在这一幕中，除其他事项外，我们还将参观公牛队球星斯科蒂·皮蓬的汽车经销店。第五幕是广播史上最伟大的时刻。请继续收听。
Act One, Bulls in Our Hearts. As a way to measure the place of the Bulls in the conscious and unconscious minds of everyday Chicagoans, consider this case, members of the radio jury. Anaheed was watching a game with her parents. They'd driven in from Detroit, the parents did, for her 26th birthday, and started arguing over Dennis Rodman.
第一幕，《心中的公牛队》。为了衡量公牛队在芝加哥普通民众显意识和潜意识中的地位，请各位广播陪审团成员考虑这样一个案例。安娜希德当时正和父母一起看球赛。她的父母从底特律开车过来为她庆祝26岁生日，结果他们因为丹尼斯·罗德曼吵了起来。
Just a quick word to public radio listeners who perhaps are not following our national basketball pastime as carefully as they might, Dennis Rodman is the player who you may have seen pictures of with the colored hair, the tattoos, the piercings. He's the one who was involved with Madonna for a while, possibly the greatest rebounder of all time. Anaheed's father did not like him. He's a rebel. He's a terrible man. Well, I'll let Anaheed tell the story.
顺便对那些可能不像我们这样关注全国篮球赛事的公共广播听众说明一下，丹尼斯·罗德曼就是你们可能看到过染着彩色头发、纹身、穿孔照片的那个球员。他就是那个曾经和麦当娜有过一段情，也可能是史上最伟大的篮板王。安娜希德的父亲不喜欢他。他是个叛逆者，是个可怕的人。好了，还是让安娜希德自己讲这个故事吧。
He said, "What kind of role model is he? He's no role model. This man is the Antichrist." And I said, "I don't think he's the Antichrist, Dad."
他说：“他算什么榜样？他根本不是榜样。这个人简直就是敌基督。”我说：“爸爸，我不觉得他是敌基督。”
What developed between them was the biggest argument Anaheed has had with her parents since she was a child, since she lived at home. It lasted for an hour. And what was remarkable about it is that it got to the most basic issues any family argument can ever get to.
他们之间爆发了安娜希德自孩提时代、自搬出家门以来与父母之间最激烈的争吵。争吵持续了一个小时。最引人注目的是，争吵上升到了任何家庭争执所能触及的最根本的问题。
He said, "You like this craziness, you are just trying to go against everything of this family. You know that's not what we stand for. You're trying to go against the family. You're trying to divide yourself as much as possible from this family, by liking Dennis Rodman."
他说：“你喜欢这种疯狂，你只是在试图违背这个家庭的一切。你知道那不是我们的立场。你是在试图对抗家庭。通过喜欢丹尼斯·罗德曼，你是在试图尽可能地与这个家庭划清界限。”
All of a sudden, I was back in high school all of a sudden. And he hadn't been so completely-- Like I mean, the fight got to the point where he was telling me, like, that I don't love him, and I'm trying to break up our relationship. He wants to have a good relationship with me. He can't even talk to me, and I don't like him, and I don't respect him. And me telling him, I don't think you listen to me, and I don't think you care about the things that I care about, and you don't even know anything about me.
那一刻，我感觉自己又回到了高中时代。他还没那么完全……我的意思是，争吵激烈到他告诉我，说我不爱他，试图破坏我们的关系。他想和我保持良好的关系。他甚至无法与我交谈，他不尊重我，我不喜欢他。我也在告诉他，我觉得你不听我说话，我觉得你不关心我所在乎的事，你甚至根本不了解我。
And it's all because of Dennis Rodman.
而这一切都是因为丹尼斯·罗德曼。
And it's all because of little Dennis Rodman.
这一切都是因为小丹尼斯·罗德曼。
It is impossible to imagine fighting like this, Anaheed says, over any other public figure.
安娜希德说，无法想象会因为其他任何公众人物而发生这样的争吵。
My dad and I are both big basketball fans, and we used to go to Pistons games all the time together when I was in high school, and that was sort of the only thing we had in common. And I think that the NBA to my dad is this really great organization. They're really wonderful, and he really loves the game. And to see somebody like Dennis Rodman sort of flip off the whole organization, I think to him sort of symbolizes me and my role in my family. And everything that I'm doing to him is what Dennis is doing to the NBA.
我和我爸爸都是篮球迷，我上高中时我们经常一起去看活塞队的比赛，那大概是我们唯一的共同语言。我认为在爸爸眼中，NBA是一个非常伟大的组织。他们真的很棒，他真的很热爱这项运动。看到丹尼斯·罗德曼这样的人某种程度上背弃了整个组织，我认为这在他眼里象征着我和我在家庭中的角色。对他来说，我所做的一切就像丹尼斯对NBA所做的那样。
Then there are the dreams. I realized a few weeks ago, actually, that even though I had not seen a Bulls game in two years, personally, and even though at the time I really didn't care less about the Bulls-- I wasn't following it at all-- the Bulls are such a presence in everyday life in Chicago-- in conversations, on the street, products, and magazines, and stuff about them everywhere-- that even I was having dreams about them. They had entered my unconscious picture of the world to that extent.
还有那些梦。事实上，几周前我意识到，尽管我已经两年没亲眼看过公牛队的比赛了，而且当时我真的对公牛队一点也不关心——我完全没在关注他们——但公牛队在芝加哥的日常生活中存在感极强——到处都是关于他们的谈话、街头广告、产品、杂志等等——以至于连我都在梦见他们。他们已经在这种程度上进入了我对世界的潜意识画面中。
So anyway, here in Chicago just last week, I went on the radio and I invited Chicagoans to call in and record their dreams about the Bulls. And people responded.
总之，就在上周的芝加哥，我在广播中邀请芝加哥听众拨打热线，记录下他们关于公牛队的梦。大家反响热烈。
Maybe five or six months ago, I was at a really stressed out time at work preparing for an audit. I had a dream during that period that the auditing team showed up at my office as planned, only the chief auditor was Michael Jordan. I was really nervous and stressed out. And there's Michael Jordan in my office. And it somehow developed, while I was having a conversation with Michael Jordan about the audit, and I wasn't completely prepared, but he knew I wasn't ready, and he decided that, in exchange for oral sexual favors, he would make sure we passed the audit. And I had a conversation with my boss about it, and my boss was, like, "Well, I can't really tell you that you should do this, but it's Michael Jordan, how bad can it be?" And we passed the audit. One of the other really funny things about this is that it's Scottie Pippen who I find absolutely just adorable, not Michael.
大约五六个月前，我在工作中压力非常大，正在准备审计。那段时间我做了一个梦，审计团队按计划出现在我的办公室，只是首席审计员是迈克尔·乔丹。我当时真的很紧张，压力很大。然后迈克尔·乔丹就出现在了我的办公室。在我和迈克尔·乔丹谈论审计的过程中，事情不知怎么就演变成，由于我准备得不够充分，但他知道我没准备好，于是他决定以口交作为交换，确保我们通过审计。我跟我老板谈了这件事，我老板说：“好吧，我不能真的建议你这么做，但那可是迈克尔·乔丹，这能有多糟糕呢？”最后我们通过了审计。这件事另一个很有趣的地方是，我真正觉得非常可爱的人是斯科蒂·皮蓬，而不是迈克尔。
I'm 52 years old. I teach at DePaul University. Last Sunday, I dreamt that I was Michael Jordan.
我今年52岁。我在德保罗大学教书。上周日，我梦见我变成了迈克尔·乔丹。
My dream was that my friend was having a bar mitzvah, and he knew Michael Jordan. And so I was going to be there at the bar mitzvah with him.
我的梦是我朋友正在举行受诫礼，他认识迈克尔·乔丹。所以我要和他一起参加那个受诫礼。
I'm in a hot tub with Michael Jordan. And he says to me, "I love my wife, but you're my best friend."
我正和迈克尔·乔丹在热水浴缸里。他对我说：“我爱我的妻子，但你是我最好的朋友。”
As weird as the Michael Jordan dreams are, the Dennis Rodman dreams are way weirder. One guy called up to describe a dream in which a mob was attacking Dennis Rodman because he was a Communist. In another dream, somebody else called in to say that a woman said that Dennis appeared in a dream of hers in a feather boa in an appliance store to tell the woman that the playoffs are fixed. It's fixed. It's done. It's fixed.
尽管迈克尔·乔丹的梦很奇怪，但丹尼斯·罗德曼的梦更离谱。有个人打电话描述了一个梦，梦中一群人因为丹尼斯·罗德曼是共产主义者而袭击他。在另一个梦里，另一个人打电话说，一位女士说丹尼斯出现在她的梦里，身穿羽毛围巾在一家家电商店告诉她季后赛是被操纵的。被操控了，一切都结束了，被操纵了。
I dreamed that Dennis Rodman was swimming in the ocean, and he was way far out, really deep. And everybody was scared that the undertow was going to drag him away.
我梦见丹尼斯·罗德曼在海里游泳，他游得很远，非常深。大家都担心暗流会把他卷走。
I had a dream that Dennis Rodman was a woman. And the two of us worked together at White Castle. Except what was interesting about Dennis was that he had no hands. And on one hand, he had a fork, and on the other hand, he had a spoon. And I felt jilted because he wouldn't talk to me. So the majority of my dream was me feeling dissed by the female Dennis Rodman with a fork and a spoon for hands.
我梦见丹尼斯·罗德曼是个女人。我们俩一起在白色城堡汉堡店工作。但丹尼斯的有趣之处在于他没有手。他的一只手上是个叉子，另一只手上是个勺子。我觉得被冷落了，因为他不跟我说话。所以我的大部分梦境都是我感觉到被长着叉子手和勺子手的女版丹尼斯所轻视。
Other people weigh in with their basketball stories, coming up.
其他人对他们的篮球故事发表了看法，马上回来。
Act Two, Bulls in a Barber Shop. A Chicago columnist wrote recently that the Bulls have become the city's royalty, but that does not really capture the half of it. The Bulls are like the soap opera that everyone in the city is watching, with this eccentric cast of characters that we all know. And watching a Bulls game, for most people, is a social event, where everybody swaps stories and theories and predictions.
第二幕，《理发店里的公牛队》。一位芝加哥专栏作家最近写道，公牛队已成为这座城市的皇室，但这并没有涵盖全部。公牛队就像城里每个人都在追看的肥皂剧，有着我们大家都熟悉的一众古怪角色。对大多数人来说，看公牛队的比赛是一种社交活动，大家在此交换故事、理论和预测。
They gonna win.
他们会赢的。
They gonna lose.
他们会输的。
They gonna sweep the whole series.
他们会横扫整个系列赛。
Shut up [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. They gonna lose today. Bulls gonna lose today.
闭嘴[听不清]。他们今天会输。公牛队今天会输。
Coleman Brothers is an old-style barbershop on Chicago's south side, been in business 34 years-- pictures on the walls of Muhammad Ali and Malcolm X, Lena Horne and Minister Louis Farrakhan, five chairs, five barbers. I visited while the third game of the Eastern Conference playoffs was on the color TV near the door. The Bulls played the Orland Magic.
科尔曼兄弟理发店是芝加哥南区一家老式理发店，已经营业34年了——墙上挂着穆罕默德·阿里、马尔科姆·艾克斯、莉娜·霍恩和路易斯·法拉罕部长的照片，有五把椅子，五位理发师。我到访时，门口附近的彩电上正在直播东部季后赛的第三场比赛。公牛队对阵奥兰多魔术队。
Richard Coleman, whose chair is nearest the door, was predicting a 15-point Bulls' victory. His brother, James, whose chair is furthest from the screen, is calling for a four-game sweep, Bulls over Orlando. But sandwiched midway between the two brothers, standing in the middle chair, Tommy was the lone dissenter in a crowded room of probably three dozen Bulls fanatics, some of whom, remember, were armed with razors. It took a certain nerve to placidly insist, hour after hour, that Shaquille O'Neal and the Magic were going to pull this series out of the bag.
椅子最靠近门口的理查德·科尔曼预测公牛队将以15分优势获胜。他的弟弟詹姆斯，椅子离屏幕最远，则预测公牛队会以4比0横扫奥兰多。但在两位兄弟中间，站在中间椅子上的汤米，在满屋子大概三打公牛队狂热粉丝中成了唯一的反对者，记住，其中一些人手里还拿着剃刀。在长达几个小时的时间里，心平气和地坚称沙奎尔·奥尼尔和魔术队能够逆转局势，这需要相当大的勇气。
I like Shaq. And they having a rough time at the moment. But can't give up the shift yet. Right, can't give up the shift.
我喜欢奥尼尔。他们现在确实处境艰难。但还不能放弃立场。对吧，不能放弃立场。
Tommy's customer, Clarence, speaks up.
汤米的顾客克拉伦斯插话了。
He's not a fan of any Chicago team.
他不是任何芝加哥球队的球迷。
They don't play no money. Chicago don't play no money. You have to fight for every penny you get. Chicago don't want to play no athletes.
他们不打钱。芝加哥不打钱。你必须为每一分钱而战。芝加哥不想请运动员。
Athletes capture the spirit of the city. You know, they still work hard. They still put forth the effort.
运动员捕捉到了这座城市的精神。要知道，他们依然努力工作。他们依然付出努力。
They'll go home broke.
他们会破产回家的。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
They'll go home broke.
他们会破产回家的。
A week before, there'd been a big discussion in Coleman Brothers about Dennis Rodman, his multi-colored hair, his tattoos, the fact that he showed up to a book signing in drag. Guys were not crazy about all this. But faced with a microphone, nobody wanted to say anything too negative about the star rebounder. And everyone had found a comfortable way to explain his behavior.
一周前，科尔曼兄弟理发店曾对丹尼斯·罗德曼展开过大讨论，谈论他五颜六色的头发、他的纹身，以及他穿着女装参加新书签售会的事。大家对这一切并不疯狂。但面对麦克风，没人想对这位明星篮板手说太负面的话。每个人都找到了解释他行为的舒适方式。
I think it's all right. I think they probably say, well, hey, he making money. This is the main thing, you know? Maybe he's doing that in order to make money.
我觉得这没什么。我觉得他们可能会说，嘿，他在赚钱。这是最主要的，你知道吗？也许他这样做是为了赚钱。
I personally don't care for his dress attire, but I think it's a marketing ploy to make more money, so what can I say?
我个人并不喜欢他的着装，但我认为这是一种为了赚更多钱的营销策略，所以我能说什么呢？
You don't think he likes to dress up in women's clothes for real.
你不认为他真的喜欢穿女装吗？
No, I personally don't think so. He's just doing it to get attention, and to sell more McDonald cups and--
不，我个人不这么认为。他只是为了博取关注，为了卖出更多的麦当劳杯子，还有……
As far as I'm concerned, man, Dennis is not all that he make up to be. I think it's a big, old marketing thing that he doing, too, man. And you see, he done gotten rich since he got here, you know. And it's all because of this crazy stuff that he does.
就我而言，伙计，丹尼斯并不像他表现出来的那样。我觉得这也是他搞的一个大营销，伙计。你看，他自从来到这里就发财了，你知道的。这一切都是因为他搞的这些疯狂行为。
What do you think about him dressing up in women's clothing at his book signing?
你觉得他穿着女装参加签售会是怎么回事？
I think Dennis, he kind of like dressing in women's clothes. I have a feeling he does. But I don't think that the man really gay. I think if he was, he would go and tell it. He been saying everything else, so why not say that?
我觉得丹尼斯，他有点喜欢穿女装。我有种感觉他喜欢。但我不认为这个男人真的是同性恋。我觉得如果他是的话，他会说出来的。他什么都敢说，为什么不说这个呢？
The Bulls-Orlando game was a pretty typical Chicago viewing experience. By half time, the Bulls were ahead 10 points. And after the winningest season in basketball history, it's hard for fans in Chicago to avoid feeling the game is in the bag.
公牛队对阵奥兰多队的比赛是一次非常典型的芝加哥观赛体验。到半场休息时，公牛队领先10分。在经历了篮球史上最辉煌的赛季后，芝加哥的球迷很难不认为胜局已定。
Bulls gonna win. Go on and wait.
公牛队会赢的。等着瞧吧。
Ha ha. No, Orlando won't come back. They're too banged up.
哈哈。不，奥兰多不会回来的。他们伤得太重了。
Bulls gonna blow them out in the second half. Bulls gonna blow them out by at least double digits.
公牛队会在下半场把他们吹走。公牛队至少会以两位数的优势碾压他们。
Except, of course, for one person, bravely standing alone, against all odds, scissors in hand, a toothpick dangling from his lips, Tommy.
当然，除了一人之外——勇敢地独自站着，力排众议，手里拿着剪刀，嘴里叼着牙签——汤米。
Orlando coming back, win by five. It ain't over till the fat lady sing.
奥兰多会反击，赢五分。不到最后关头，胜负未定。
People stream in and out of the barber shop. Everyone comments on the game. In the second half, when Michael Jordan takes a nasty spill, a customer shouts, "Superman's down!" The man sitting next to me introduces himself as Mr. Popcorn, a customer of Coleman's beginning 34 years ago, and a former high school basketball player himself.
人们进进出出理发店。每个人都在评论比赛。下半场，当迈克尔·乔丹重重摔倒时，一位顾客大喊：“超人倒下了！”坐在我旁边的人自我介绍叫“爆米花先生”，是科尔曼理发店34年前的顾客，他自己以前也是高中篮球队员。
That's what I played, basketball, baseball, football.
那就是我打的，篮球、棒球、橄榄球。
So when you see these players, is there some player who you really relate to the way they play?
那么当你看到这些球员时，有没有哪位球员让你对他们的比赛方式产生共鸣？
I relate to Michael Jordan. That's the way I would play. Play it hard, man. You know, a guard. Get the ball to the guy who can shoot, you know.
我能跟迈克尔·乔丹产生共鸣。那就是我的打法。努力去打，伙计。你知道，作为一个后卫。把球传给能投篮的人，你懂的。
The effect of the Bulls on the local economy is usually measured in millions of dollars, but it extends to 1,000 small shops like this one. Mr. Popcorn says that if the Bulls take the championship, he's going to sell Bulls T-shirts himself. And before long, he asked me the question that he asked a lot of customers at Colemans.
公牛队对当地经济的影响通常以数百万美元计算，但它延伸到了像这样的一千家小店。爆米花先生说，如果公牛队拿到冠军，他自己也要卖公牛队的T恤。没过多久，他问了我一个他问过科尔曼很多顾客的问题。
I have a Bull watch. Would you like to buy one?
我有一块公牛队手表。你想买一块吗？
No, no.
不，不。
What you mean no? I'm going to sell it to you cheap because you're a radio guy.
你说的“不”是什么意思？因为你是广播员，我便宜卖给你。
Nah.
不了。
I thought you said you was a Bull fan.
我以为你说你是公牛队球迷。
I am.
我是。
By the third quarter, I am the proud owner of a Bull's watch, marked down from $12 to $5. By the fourth quarter, with two minutes left on the clock, the Bulls leading by 17 points, and Michael Jordan apparently already sent to the showers, even these die-hard Chicago fans started making jokes. "What else is on?" one guy asked. "What's on the other channels?"
到第三节结束时，我成了公牛队手表的骄傲拥有者，价格从12美元砍到了5美元。到了第四节，计时器还剩两分钟，公牛队领先17分，而迈克尔·乔丹显然已经被换下场去洗澡了，连这些芝加哥死忠粉也开始开玩笑了。“还有什么好看的？”一个人问。“其他频道在放什么？”
James pays off a bet he'd actually made against the Bulls with Mr. Popcorn. Guys start talking about a sweep, a sweep, that is, of four games in a row. And when the final buzzer goes off, it turns out that Richard's prediction, a 15-point spread, is exactly where the game turned out.
詹姆斯兑现了他和爆米花先生打赌的赌注，他之前其实赌公牛队会输。大家开始谈论“横扫”，也就是连赢四场。当终场哨声响起时，事实证明，理查德关于15分分差的预测，正是比赛最终的结果。
What did I tell them before the game started? What did I tell you?
比赛开始前我是怎么告诉他们的？我是怎么告诉你们的？
15.
15分。
I told you they was going to win it. They gonna run away with it. Orlando, they're just an inexperienced team that doesn't have the experience to play with the Bulls.
我告诉过你们他们会赢。他们会大胜。奥兰多，他们只是一支缺乏经验的球队，没有和公牛队过招的资本。
Oh, you said 15?
哦，你说的是15分？
That's what I said before they started.
那是比赛开始前我说的。
Did anybody bet you? Somebody should have took that.
有人和你下注了吗？应该有人接这个盘的。
I told you they gonna win. And if I tell you-- don't ever forget this-- if I tell you an elephant roost up a tree, you better look up there, you gonna see an elephant.
我告诉过你们他们会赢。而且如果你听我说——永远别忘了这点——如果我告诉你大象能爬上树，你最好往上看，你一定会看到一只大象。
Tommy looked around at the celebrating with a smile. I asked him for a final verdict on the Bulls.
汤米微笑着环顾着庆祝的人群。我问了他对公牛队的最终判决。
Seattle, they gonna take it.
西雅图，他们会拿下的。
Man, you just don't give up, do you?
伙计，你真是死不悔改，对吧？
Seattle gonna take them old men. Quote. Seattle, they gonna take it. Quote.
西雅图会搞定那帮老头子。引用我的话。西雅图，他们会拿下的。引用。
Seattle gonna get the same thing the Magic's getting, a whooping, old-fashioned whooping.
西雅图会遭遇和魔术队一样的下场，一顿暴揍，老派的那种暴揍。
Then we all looked up, and through the plate glass window in front of the barber shop, we saw a car pull up. A guy climbs out with a brand-new broom in his hand, and strides toward the barber shop.
然后我们都抬起头，透过理发店前面的玻璃窗，看到一辆车停了下来。一个家伙手里拿着一把崭新的扫帚钻出车门，大步朝理发店走来。
He bringing the broom to Tommy.
他正把扫帚拿给汤米。
The guy walks in and stands, broom in hand, near the door.
那个人走进来，手里拿着扫帚，站在门边。
What's the problem?
有什么问题吗？
I told you I was going to come back up here now.
我告诉过你我现在要上来了。
Hey Tommy, you didn't think they was going to sweep, huh?
嘿，汤米，你没想到他们会横扫对手吧？
It ain't no sweep.
这根本不算横扫。
Tommy, I can't hear you, man. Did you see the bull run down the street? Was Shaquille on it?
汤米，我听不见你说什么，伙计。你看到公牛队沿街游行了吗？奥尼尔在上面吗？
The guy's name is Derek, a regular at Colemans.
那家伙叫德里克，是科尔曼店里的常客。
Tell him I got to go home and celebrate, man. Me and all my Bull friend buddies, we going to to go celebrate. You going to jump on the bandwagon sooner or later, Tommy. We gonna make a believer out of you. No [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
告诉他我得回家庆祝了。我和我所有的公牛队朋友们，我们要去庆祝。汤米，你迟早也会加入我们的阵营。我们会让你成为信徒的。不……（听不清）。
Tommy's unnerved.
汤米感到不安。
I've already talked to Gary Payton, and boy, we gonna do it in 4-2. Gary Payton, Seattle.
我已经和加里·佩顿谈过了，伙计，我们要在四比二拿下比赛。加里·佩顿，西雅图。
You gotta respect somebody who'll publicly argue against what may be the best basketball team ever to play the game. It takes a certain amount of guts. But soon enough, this Bulls team will have to fade, especially given the age of players, mostly in their 30s. And it can be a sobering thought that, years from now, when all these guys are watching some new incarnation of the Bulls, this is the moment, this is the time right now, that they're going to remember together.
你必须尊重那些敢于公开反对可能是史上最强篮球队的人。这需要一定的胆量。但用不了多久，这支公牛队终将黯淡，考虑到球员们的年龄，大部分都在30岁以上。想到多年以后，当这群人看着新一代的公牛队时，意识到这一刻、此时此刻，就是他们共同铭记的时光，这让人感到清醒而沉重。
One of the other customers, a guy whose name, I think, was Edgar, sat in Richard's chair, the electric clippers whirring, and contemplated this.
另一位顾客，我想他叫埃德加，坐在理查德的椅子上，电推剪嗡嗡作响，他陷入了沉思。
You should be happy that you can say that, hey, I was sitting there watching them when they did all that. So I know I am. Tell my grandchildren when I get real old, you know, I was there when the Bulls won all them games, probably I'll say I went to a couple of games, you know.
你应该感到高兴，因为你可以说，嘿，他们创造这一切时我就坐在那里看着。所以我知道我很庆幸。等我老了，我会告诉孙子们，公牛队赢得那些比赛时我见证了一切，可能我还会说我去看过几场比赛，你知道的。
Yeah, remember those days when Michael Jordan was still playing at his peak? Remember when Rodman was the only guy in the league with multi-colored hair? Remember when they were on that legendary team together, Dennis, Michael, Scottie?
是啊，还记得迈克尔·乔丹处于巅峰期的那些日子吗？还记得罗德曼是联盟里唯一一个留着五彩头发的家伙吗？还记得他们——丹尼斯、迈克尔、斯科蒂——共同效力于那支传奇球队的时候吗？
That's how it's going to be, for everybody that was here when the Bulls was doing this. That's how it's going to be.
对于所有亲历公牛队这段辉煌时期的人来说，情况就是这样。情况就是这样。
Act Three, The Meaning of Basketball. I wonder if it would be possible to make up a more pretentious name for a section of a radio program, The Meaning of Basketball. The fact is, the meaning of basketball is whatever each player and each fan makes of it, right? Stay with me here, OK? Loving sports, I am arguing to you right now, is like any kind of love. It's idiosyncratic and there's no way to account for what happens to grab your imagination and your heart about a game.
第三幕，篮球的意义。我不知道是否能为广播节目的一个板块起一个更自命不凡的名字——“篮球的意义”。事实是，篮球的意义取决于每个球员和每个球迷赋予它什么，对吧？听着，我向你争辩，热爱体育运动就像任何形式的爱一样。它是独特的，没有人能解释为什么某件事会触动你的想象力和心灵。
In this act of the show, we bring you a couple of stories from different parts of the country. And we begin right here in Chicago. I know that will be, at this point in the show, a tremendous surprise to you. We begin here in Chicago, an explanation of one particular pleasure of the game.
在节目的这一部分，我们将为你带来来自全国各地的几个故事。我们从芝加哥开始。我知道在节目的这个阶段，这对你们来说是一个巨大的惊喜。我们从芝加哥开始，解释这项运动的一种独特乐趣。
There is no greater pleasure than being a Bulls hater in a Bulls-loving town.
没有什么比在公牛队狂热的城市里做一个“公牛黑”更大的乐趣了。
David Isaacson is a Chicago playwright, and he is not just any Bulls hater. He's a Bulls hater of the most reviled kind in Chicago. He is a fan of the Detroit Pistons. In 1988, '89, and '90, the Bulls lost the NBA playoffs to the Pistons, a team that most Chicagoans see as thuggish, dirty, and worst of all, whiney.
大卫·艾萨克森是一位芝加哥剧作家，他不仅仅是一个普通的公牛黑。他是芝加哥最受唾弃的那种公牛黑。他是底特律活塞队的粉丝。在1988、1989和1990年，公牛队在NBA季后赛中输给了活塞队，那支被大多数芝加哥人视为暴徒、肮脏、最糟糕的是爱发牢骚的球队。
How to describe the sweet, sweet pleasure of entering a drinking establishment full of established drinkers, and proudly letting out a roar whenever the diminutive Detroit guard Isiah Thomas scooped a layup high off the backboard into the basket, or Vinnie "The Microwave" Johnson would launch a shot with, oh, three of four opposing players hanging from his thick arms and legs, or Joe Dumars covering the great god Michael Jordan would, through fainting, decoying, and overplaying, manipulate MJ into the waiting arms and oh-so solid body of Bill Laimbeer.
该如何描述这种甜蜜的乐趣：走进一家挤满常客的酒吧，每当底特律矮个后卫以赛亚·托马斯将上篮高高抛向篮板入网，或者维尼·“微波炉”·约翰逊在三四个对手拉扯着他的粗壮手臂和腿的情况下投篮命中，又或者乔·杜马斯防守伟大的神迈克尔·乔丹时，通过虚晃、诱敌和过分逼防，操纵MJ撞进比尔·兰比尔等待已久且坚如磐石的身体怀抱中时，我都自豪地大声欢呼。
To let out a roar as those around me grumbled, all the time harboring grandiose notions that, in so roaring, I was courting a barroom beating at the hands of, say, those five beefy guys at the bar with a pitcher of Old Style, the identical number 23 red-and-white jerseys, and, shaved into their crew cuts Anthony Mason style, the letters B-U-L-L-S, respectively.
当周围的人抱怨时，我发出欢呼声，同时还怀揣着宏大的想法：通过这样的欢呼，我是在自找挨揍，比如被吧台那五个壮汉修理，他们喝着大杯的Old Style啤酒，穿着一模一样的23号红白球衣，头发剪成安东尼·梅森式的平头，分别刻着B-U-L-L-S这几个字母。
To stand alone against a sea of popular opinion, to be associated with a great malevolent force, shady underground figures, the Detroit Pistons, this was a spectacular seduction. To be a Pistons fan in Chicago, like being a Navy fan at West Point, or a Dodgers fan in Manhattan in the old days, seemed heroic. I was Pancho Villa on a border raid, Bartleby the Scrivener telling his boss, I would prefer not to, Brando in the Wild One rebelling against, what do you got? It was the same contrary impulse, however, the thrill of being the lone fan, that turned my girlfriend against me.
独自对抗舆论的海洋，与一股邪恶的强大力量、阴暗的地下人物——底特律活塞队——为伍，这是一种奇妙的诱惑。在芝加哥做活塞队的球迷，就像在西点军校做海军球迷，或者在旧时代的曼哈顿做道奇队球迷，显得非常英雄主义。我感觉自己像是边境袭击中的潘乔·比利亚，是那个对老板说“我宁愿不这样做”的抄写员巴特比，是《飞车党》中反抗一切的马龙·白兰度。然而，正是这种反叛的冲动，这种做孤独球迷的快感，导致我的女朋友背叛了我。
Accepted into an elite east coast graduate school, she suddenly found herself surrounded by elite east coast fans of the New York Knickerbockers. Though up to this point, her interest in the Bulls had consisted wholly in the observation that point guard B.J. Armstrong was so cute, and, in an almost obsessive curiosity, regarding that odd bald patch in the middle of center Bill Cartwright's beard. Her grad school experience turned her into a raving rooter for the team that I so proudly despised. In a world of Knicks lovers, she chose to be the lone fan of the Bulls.
她被东海岸的一所精英研究生院录取，突然发现自己被一群纽约尼克斯队的精英球迷包围了。虽然在此之前，她对公牛队的兴趣仅限于观察控球后卫BJ·阿姆斯特朗很可爱，以及对中锋比尔·卡特赖特胡子中间那块奇怪的秃斑有着近乎强迫症的好奇。她的研究生经历使她变成了那支我引以为傲地蔑视的球队的狂热支持者。在尼克斯迷的世界里，她选择成为唯一的公牛队球迷。
Watching games with her became an unsettling experience. When our teams would clash, I would catch her eyeing me strangely, as if contemplating which Bill Laimbeer thrown elbow or Rick Mahorn cheap shot I was complicit in, in what ways I, the bully by association, might have wronged those near and dear to her, and subsequently, what punishments or deprivations she might legitimately inflict on me in response.
和她一起看比赛成了一种令人不安的经历。当我们的球队发生冲突时，我会捕捉到她奇怪地看着我，仿佛在思考我参与了比尔·兰比尔的哪一次肘击或里克·马洪的哪一次脏动作，思考我这个“共犯”以何种方式伤害了她所珍视的人，以及随后她可能会合法地对我施加什么惩罚或剥夺。
This year, as every one in the world now knows, the Bulls won 72 games and lost a mere 10, making them, numerically at least, the most successful team of all time. It is also the year I, without meaning to, traded in the great and noble pleasure of publicly hating the Bulls in every bar, tavern, and speak easy of this beer-swilling town for the rather common, tawdry pleasure of joining the masses in whooping up every Jordan jumper, Pippen put-back, and Kukoc [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
今年，正如全世界都知道的那样，公牛队赢了72场，仅输了10场，这使他们在数据上成为史上最成功的球队。这也是我无意中放弃了在芝加哥每家酒吧、酒馆和小酒馆公开痛恨公牛队的高尚乐趣，转而加入了大众的行列，为乔丹的每一个跳投、皮蓬的每一次补篮和库科奇的……（听不清）而欢呼，这种平庸、庸俗的乐趣。
And why? Well, for one thing, three of my old Pistons have joined the current version of the Bulls. John "Spider" Salley, who can still block a shot with the best of them. James "Buddha" Edwards, who, at the age of 40, still successfully practices his specialty, the fade away chip shot from the paint. And of course, Dennis "The Worm" Rodman. I've always loved his sloppy relentless enthusiasm on the court. But what's won me over lately is his T-shirt collection. Recent slogans have included, "I'm not gay, but my boyfriend is," and "I don't mind straight people, as long as they act gay in public."
为什么？首先，我的三个前活塞队员加入了现役公牛队。约翰·“蜘蛛”·萨利，他盖帽的能力依然出众。詹姆斯·“佛祖”·爱德华兹，40岁了还在练习他的绝活——油漆区外后仰跳投。当然，还有丹尼斯·“大虫”·罗德曼。我一直很喜欢他在球场上那种邋遢而执着的劲头。但最近让我折服的是他的T恤收藏。最近的标语包括“我不是同性恋，但我男朋友是”，以及“我不介意直人，只要他们在公共场合表现得像同性恋”。
But more than that, I think one can say that, for me, familiarity has bred respect. Most of these Bulls are my age or older. Jordan's my age, and as my body changes, as joints respond less readily, bruises take longer to heal, and hangovers get harder to cure, I have grown to appreciate MJ's ability to recreate himself. The mad dash fearless dunking of his youth has been replaced by safer, more adult practices. Watch as Michael becomes a post-up player. Watch his transformation into a master of the three-point heave. See Michael learn and perfect the unstoppable Larry Bird fade away.
但不仅如此，我想说的是，对我而言，熟悉产生了尊重。这些公牛队员大多和我同龄或更大。乔丹和我同龄，随着我的身体发生变化，关节反应不再那么灵敏，瘀伤恢复得更慢，宿醉也更难治愈，我开始欣赏MJ重塑自我的能力。他年轻时那种疯狂无畏的扣篮已被更安全、更成熟的打法所取代。看迈克尔如何成为一名背身单打球员。看他转型为三分投篮大师。看迈克尔学习并完善那不可阻挡的拉里·伯德式后仰跳投。
Facing the cameras for the gagillionth time, following a perfect evening spent revealing the tragic flaws of yet another squad of opponents who had been, until meeting the Bulls, flirting with respectability, Jordan, Pippen, and their teammates exude a pungent, delicious aura. Invincibility is, inevitably, sexy. These are Bodhisattvas, approaching Buddhahood, utterly at peace with themselves, and yet at the same time, striving mightily for the next level of enlightenment. Gone for me the rebel's glory. Gone the exalted status of an arch-antagonist. Gone the thrill of withstanding the Bulls fans contumely. Woe, woe is me. Go, go Bulls.
第无数次面对镜头，在又一个完美的夜晚过后，揭示了另一支直到遇到公牛队前还假装体面的球队的致命弱点，乔丹、皮蓬和他们的队友散发出一种浓郁、美味的气息。不可战胜终究是性感的。他们是菩萨，接近佛境，与自我完全和谐，同时又在为下一个开悟层次而努力。叛逆的荣耀离我而去。反派领袖的高贵地位离我而去。承受公牛球迷嘲讽的刺激也离我而去。悲哀啊，悲哀。加油，加油公牛。
David Isaacson is a Chicago playwright. And now we have for you this rap, part of which seems to be a burgeoning genre of music that perhaps you have not heard of, basketball stars doing raps, some of them, most of them, profoundly mediocre. This one from Seattle Sonics star Gary Payton.
大卫·艾萨克森是一位芝加哥剧作家。现在我们为你带来这段说唱，这似乎是一种新兴音乐流派的一部分，也许你还没听说过：篮球明星说唱，其中一些——大部分——水平平平。这一首来自西雅图超音速队的明星加里·佩顿。
[SINGING] Living legal and large, GP's the man in charge. He's got game on you. Coming up as a youngster, the G had faith. I always pray to God that I make it one day. And now my dreams are alive. My mama used to tell me, you gotta strive and try to be the best that you can be to survive. Now I'm living legal and large, got a fat bank account and a bunch of credit cards. Making the opponents bow down on the floor. If you want to hum [UNINTELLIGIBLE], it's because I love the sport. Half the fans yelling for joy because I'm bouncing the ball on 'em like Shanaynay. They call me Payday. The big ball handler. Yeah, yeah, what you want. Slam dunk, hit a three. Talk a little junk. Huh. It's all good if you're feeling inferior, because I'm superior, much better than the average brother. Me and my crew sticks tight when we step in the clubs, we're not getting the [UNINTELLIGIBLE], right. Living legal and large, I'm the man in charge.
（歌唱）生活合法且阔绰，GP是当家人。他能在比赛中压制你。从小时候起，我就有信念。我总是祈求上帝有一天能成功。现在我的梦想实现了。我妈妈常告诉我，你必须努力奋斗，力争成为最好的自己才能生存。现在我生活合法且阔绰，银行账户里钱多多，还有一堆信用卡。让对手在球场上鞠躬。如果你想……（听不清），那是因为我热爱这项运动。有一半球迷欢呼雀跃，因为我像Shanaynay一样在他们面前运球。他们叫我“发薪日”。我是大球手。没错，没错，你想要什么。扣篮、投三分。垃圾话讲几句。呵。感觉低人一等是很正常的，因为我更胜一筹，比普通人强多了。我和我的兄弟们步调一致，我们走进夜店，我们不会……（听不清），对吧。生活合法且阔绰，我是当家人。
Coming up, trophies, the strangest basketball dream of all, and more, in one minute, when our program continues.
稍后，奖杯、最奇怪的篮球梦，以及更多内容，一分钟后节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. And this week, as every week in our program, we have chosen a theme. We've invited a variety of writers and performers to take a whack at that theme. And this week is the Chicago Bulls. Let me get some music going here for this, when I say their names. This week is the Chicago Bulls.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。本周，和往常的每一周一样，我们选择了一个主题。我们邀请了各种作家和表演者来挑战这个主题。这周的主题是芝加哥公牛队。当我念出他们的名字时，让我放点音乐。本周是芝加哥公牛队。
[MUSIC - "ROCK AND ROLL, PART 2" BY GARY GLITTER]
（音乐 - 加里·格里特的《摇滚乐，第二部分》）
There we go. Doesn't that give a satisfying feeling to hear it? It's just one good reason to do a show about the Bulls, that you can play this song over and over. This week, as the Chicago Bull's careen past the winningest season in basketball history, through the NBA playoffs, our theme is basketball. And let us ask the question again, what is the meaning of sports? The answer, trophies. Well, looked at it in one way, that's the answer.
这就对了。听到这个，难道没有一种满足感吗？做一个关于公牛队的节目有一个很好的理由，那就是你可以一遍又一遍地播放这首歌。本周，随着芝加哥公牛队冲过篮球史上胜率最高的赛季，进入NBA季后赛，我们的主题是篮球。让我们再问一次，体育的意义是什么？答案是，奖杯。好吧，从某种角度看，这就是答案。
You know, you compete, you try to win, you make it through the regular season, through the playoffs. The further you get, the bigger the trophy-- sort of. The problem is that trophies do not age well. The further you get from the triumphant moment when you win the trophy, the uglier the trophy becomes. Until, after decades, they just look like dusty, aging clutter, carrying no glory, no numinous power.
你知道，你竞争，你努力赢球，你经历了常规赛，进入了季后赛。你走得越远，奖杯就越大——大概是这样。问题是奖杯不会随着时间增加价值。当你赢得奖杯的那一刻离你越远，奖杯就显得越丑陋。直到几十年后，它们看起来就像积满灰尘、日渐陈旧的杂物，不再承载荣耀，也没有任何神圣的力量。
Well, one of our producers, Nancy Updike, talked to a friend of hers, a big amateur basketball player, about all this.
好吧，我们的制片人之一南希·厄普代克和她的一位朋友——一位资深的业余篮球运动员——谈论了这件事。
When I met up with my friend Mary to talk about basketball, she was having some trouble with her trophies. She'd just moved to a new apartment, and her new place was small, so small that a bunch of high school trophies would just dominate any room they were in. She had the trophies in a box in the living room, and we sat on the floor pulling out fake silver statuettes of girls in coolots, reaching ever upward, hopeful and fit, like in Soviet propaganda posters.
当我遇见朋友玛丽谈论篮球时，她正为自己的奖杯发愁。她刚搬进一个新公寓，空间很小，小到足以让一堆高中奖杯占据任何房间。她把奖杯放在客厅的一个盒子里，我们坐在地板上，掏出那些仿银色的女孩雕像，她们穿着裙裤，向上伸展，充满希望且健美，就像苏联宣传海报里那样。
So can't you see, like, feeling really tough walking home with something this big, especially if you hold it like this?
你看，手里拿着这么大的东西走回家，感觉真的很强悍，特别是如果你像这样拿着它？
Sure. Grab that baby by the base.
当然。抓住那个底座。
Then she found one that was not like the others, sort of hard to understand, actually. Picture this, a thick slice of wood, sanded and shellacked and mounted with a miniature rim and backboard, and then, leaping across the front, a stick figure made of roofing nails going in for a slam dunk. Mary identified this as her 1978 girls varsity team trophy from Cardinal Dougherty High School. And the girls, she said, had not been pleased with the trophy at all.
然后她发现了一个和其他完全不同的，其实挺难理解的。想象一下，一块厚厚的木片，打磨并涂上漆，上面安装着迷你篮筐和篮板，然后，一个用屋顶钉子做成的火柴人正跃起准备扣篮。玛丽称这是她1978年红衣主教多尔蒂高中的校队奖杯。她说，女孩们对这个奖杯一点也不满意。
It's ugly, isn't it?
它很丑，对吧？
Yeah, it is truly-- It's so damned--
是的，确实……太该死的……
We were all really unhappy. We wanted, like, a traditional--
我们都很不开心。我们想要那种传统的……
Will you give it to me?
你能把它给我吗？
[LAUGHS] Yes.
（笑）可以。
I love it. I want it.
我爱死它了。我想要它。
We would rather have had, like, the also ugly but much more acceptable old version of trophies than those trophies.
我们宁愿要那种虽然也丑但更能接受的旧式奖杯，而不是这些奖杯。
Oh, sure. Oh, sure. I mean, if you're a 13-year-old girl, you don't want to be walking home with that. You want that.
哦，当然。当然。我的意思是，如果你是个13岁的女孩，你不会想带着那个走回家。你会想要那一个。
Right, right.
对，对。
--that's a trophy.
那才叫奖杯。
You want something that goes up high in the sky, not something that is a slice of a tree.
你想要那种高耸入云的东西，而不是一片树木的横截面。
You don't want a tree slice.
你不想要一片木头。
A slice of a tree with a nail stick figure soldered together, doing the one thing that you know you'll never be able to do-- dunk.
一片树木横截面，上面焊着个钉子火柴人，做着你知道自己永远无法完成的事——扣篮。
Was that something that you all discussed?
那是你们大家讨论过的事情吗？
Oh, yeah. And we also thought that that was the only reason we'd never been in the NBA. Luckily for us, we all thought, well, you know, we're really some of the best players on the face of the Earth. You know, when you're a 16-year-old girl who's playing at a tough Catholic league school, like you think, yeah, we're good enough. I'm just as good as Maurice Cheeks. And you know, the Doctor would like to play with me, Doctor J. And we could attribute our lack of success in the NBA to the fact that we were girls, soon to be women, who would never dunk. And that's all that was keeping us from it.
哦，是的。我们还认为这就是我们没进NBA的唯一原因。幸运的是，我们都认为，嗯，你知道，我们真的是地球上最好的球员之一。你知道，当你是一个在强悍的天主教联盟学校打球的16岁女孩时，你会觉得，是的，我们够强。我和莫里斯·奇克斯一样好。你知道，J博士肯定想和我一起打球。我们可以把在NBA缺乏成就归因于我们是女孩，即将成为女人，永远无法扣篮。这就是阻碍我们的全部原因。
Mary handed me the wood-sliced trophy. And when I reached to touch the stick figure, I realized that one of its feet was on a pivot, so I could actually make it go in for the dunk. Once I discovered this, it was impossible not to do it over and over and over. The trophy was completely hypnotizing, a disturbing artifact from an artistic period best forgotten.
玛丽把木片奖杯递给我。当我伸手去碰那个火柴人时，我发现它的一只脚上有个枢轴，所以我真的可以让它做出扣篮动作。一旦发现这一点，就忍不住一遍又一遍地做下去。这个奖杯完全让人着迷，是一件来自一个最好被遗忘的艺术时期的令人不安的文物。
The art of the late '70s, especially in Catholic religion textbooks and churches and stuff was so ugly.
70年代末的艺术，特别是在天主教宗教课本和教堂里之类的东西，真是太丑了。
Who knew there was even a genre of late-'70s Catholic textbook art worlds. You know, that whole scene.
谁知道竟然还有一种70年代末天主教教科书艺术流派。你知道，那种整个场景。
I'm afraid I've been so influenced by it, it's like, you know--
恐怕我受其影响太深，就像，你知道……
I need to walk away.
我需要走开。
--those little ink drawings that are just a little bit off on-purpose. You know what I mean? And the on-purposeness of it is just, like--
那些刻意画得有点走样的墨水画。你知道我的意思吗？那种刻意感简直……
It makes you want to grit your teeth.
让人想咬牙切齿。
--oh, help me. Yeah, right, right. You can always hear a Cat Stevens song playing in the background.
噢，救命。是啊，对，对。你总能在背景里听到凯特·史蒂文斯的歌。
As a kid, Mary played basketball mostly with her older brother, Daniel. The two of them roamed around the city together looking for pickup games whenever they could, all summer, every weekend, even at night, because the court down the street had lights. It was a way to get out of the house, to escape the chaos of 11 kids in a working class Irish family in a too-small house on the edge of Northeast Philadelphia. Basketball was a place of clear rules and gestures that always made sense. And home was a place where you could get hit for no reason, or find yourself still hungry at the end of a meal. Mary remembered being hungry a lot growing up, a fact always cheerfully denied by the nuns at school.
小时候，玛丽大部分时间是和哥哥丹尼尔一起打篮球。他们整个夏天、每个周末，甚至晚上，都会在城市里寻找斗牛赛，因为街尽头的球场有灯。这是一种离开家、逃避费城东北部边缘一个小房子里11个孩子生活混乱的方式。篮球是一个规则清晰、动作有意义的地方。而家里却是一个你会无缘无故挨打，或在饭后依然感到饥饿的地方。玛丽记得成长过程中经常感到饥饿，而学校的修女们总是乐呵呵地否认这一点。
The message was, you couldn't be hungry because your parents are saints. And they especially directed it to our family and all the other families that had a lot of kids in them, that our parents were saints because they worked so hard to provide for us. So I thought that I was just extraordinarily greedy that I would want to eat when I was hungry. I think that playing basketball was a way to say, you know, if I could use my body in this way, that got me status and attention and a certain amount of prestige, then my body was OK in a way, even though it was-- I mean, I was way too skinny when I was a kid.
传达的信息是，你不可能感到饿，因为你的父母是圣人。她们特别针对我们的家庭和其他有很多孩子的家庭，说我们的父母是圣人，因为他们辛勤工作养育我们。所以我以为我特别贪婪，才会感到饥饿时想吃东西。我认为打篮球是一种表达方式，你知道，如果我能这样使用我的身体，能带给我地位、关注和一定的声望，那么我的身体在某种程度上就是可以的，尽管它……我是说，我小时候太瘦了。
And it was cause for concern for the school nurse a couple times. And playing basketball was a way to say, you know, you're not going to have neural damage from being malnourished. You're just going to have these other minor malnourished problems.
有好几次这引起了校医的担忧。打篮球是一种方式，告诉人们，你不会因为营养不良而造成神经损伤。你只会遇到其他一些轻微的营养不良问题。
Another good thing about basketball was that it was cheap. Mary bought the family a rim and a basketball for their backyard when she was only seven or eight, using her first communion money, $65 in $5 increments from everyone in her huge family. The only equipment she really needed and could never afford were good shoes.
篮球的另一个好处是便宜。玛丽在七八岁时，用她的初领圣体钱，从大家庭里的每个人那里凑齐了5美元面额的65美元，给家里买了一个篮筐和篮球。她真正需要却买不起的唯一装备就是一双好鞋。
She always had those supermarket checkout line shoes with the hard plastic soles that were completely embarrassing, of course, but also had no grippability. So she would be running down a court and go sliding and be called for traveling. So one year, she got up the courage to ask a girl down the block for her old shoes.
她总是穿着那种超市结账台买的鞋，底子是硬塑料的，当然非常尴尬，而且毫无抓地力。所以当她在球场上奔跑时，总是会滑倒，然后被判走步。所以有一年，她鼓起勇气向街头的女孩要旧鞋。
Her name was Karen, and she had really nice Beta Bullets, high tops, white. And I wanted her sneakers because I knew she was getting new ones. And in our neighborhood, there is the practice of throwing your old sneakers up over the telephone wires when you're done with them. And most of them were hardly worn out at all. I mean, a lot of them, you could see that there was tread missing, but it's not like you had ripped through the top of them.
她叫凯伦，她有一双非常漂亮的Beta Bullets高帮鞋，白色的。我想要她的运动鞋，因为我知道她要买新鞋了。在我们街区，有一种习俗，就是穿旧的运动鞋不穿了就扔到电话线上。它们中的大多数几乎没怎么磨损。我是说，很多时候你能看到鞋底花纹磨没了，但并不是说鞋面都磨烂了。
And I'd asked her for them, and she said, yeah, that she would give them to me when she got her new ones. I thought that it was a little bit weird that I would ask somebody for their used shoes, but we had other clothes that were used from other people. And she was tough, and she kind of had this-- she seemed like she'd be the kind of person that could keep something like that to her and would know what it meant. And she did. She never told anybody, except, of course, the most important person that she shouldn't have told, her mother.
我问她要，她说好，等她拿到新鞋就给我。我当时觉得问别人要旧鞋有点奇怪，但我们确实穿过别人给的衣服。她很坚强，她看起来好像那种能保守秘密、懂得那意味着什么的人。她确实做到了。除了她不该告诉的最重要的人——她的妈妈——之外，她谁也没告诉。
And her mother got really upset and told her that she couldn't give them to me. And there they were, hanging up on the telephone wire, my sneakers.
她妈妈非常生气，告诉她不能给我。然后它们就在那儿，挂在电话线上，我的运动鞋。
And I'm sure that her mom did that because she was afraid that if I came home with a pair of used sneakers that it would be insulting to my mother. I'm sure that they all had this understanding of themselves, like you don't insult one of your peers by giving their kids your crappy shoes even though they're better than the crappy shoes that you bought for them.
我肯定她妈妈这样做是因为她害怕如果我带着一双旧球鞋回家，会是对我母亲的侮辱。我敢肯定，她们之间有这种默契，比如不要通过给朋友孩子破烂鞋子来羞辱对方，尽管那些鞋比她们自己买的破鞋好得多。
But there were always really beautiful sneakers hanging up on the wires, and there was no way to get them, no way at all. They just floated up there. And you know what? I think that's when I decided that platonic idealism was true. There really was a perfect thing that I would never experience, at least while I played in that Catholic league. And only I could see them for what they were. They only saw worn-out tread. I saw a season of unforeseen high statistics.
但线上面总挂着非常漂亮的球鞋，却没法弄到，一点办法也没有。它们就那样悬浮在那里。你知道吗？我想那就是我决定“柏拉图式理想主义”是真的时刻。确实存在某种完美的东西，我永远也体验不到，至少在我效力那个天主教联盟的时候是这样。只有我能看出它们的价值。她们只看到了磨损的底纹。而我看到了一季意想不到的亮眼数据。
We talked for two hours about basketball. And we kept returning to the dunk, that special thing boys can do and girls can't. And the cruelty of the dunk on that wood-sliced trophy, a dunk by a stick figure made of nails, driving home their 18-year-old sense of frustration. They could be the best ball handlers, the best guards, and it didn't matter worth a damn because they couldn't dunk. All of that captured forever in the last trophy most of them would ever receive.
我们谈了两个小时的篮球。我们不停地回到扣篮这个话题，那是男孩能做而女孩做不到的特殊动作。以及那个木片奖杯上扣篮动作的残酷性，一个由钉子制成的火柴人正在扣篮，那突显了她们18岁时那种挫败感。她们可以是最好的控卫、最好的后卫，但那根本不重要，因为她们不会扣篮。所有这一切都被永久地定格在她们大多数人收到的最后一个奖杯上。
I think it was really kind of thoughtless in the way that thoughtless things can sometimes have a really nasty edge to them. And we had a woman on our team who was African-American who was, like 6'3, and she couldn't dunk the ball. You know what I mean? It was like there was no one that we knew who could dunk the ball, not a single woman that we knew. And we knew some tall women. We knew women who were in college. I mean, I used to have a dream, a recurring dream that I dunked the ball.
我认为这种行为很无礼，有时候无礼的事情会带有一种真正令人厌恶的边缘。我们队里有一个非裔美国女性，她有6英尺3英寸高，但她也扣不了篮。你知道我的意思吗？就好像我们认识的人里没有一个能扣篮的，一个女性都没有。我们确实认识一些高个子女性。我们认识上大学的女性。我是说，我曾经有一个梦，一个重复出现的梦，梦见我扣篮了。
What were the circumstances?
那是种什么情况？
I was on the baseline.
我在底线。
I'm so glad you asked.
我很高兴你问了这个。
I was in the same position all the time. And it wasn't like kinds of dunks that you see in real life, like that even the best players can do. This was a spectacular dunk, because I didn't just get my hands up over the rim, I sailed over the rim with my feet and got above the basket and just slammed the ball down through the thing. My whole body was above the rim.
我总是处于同一个位置。那不是你在现实生活中看到的扣篮，甚至最好的球员也不一定能做到。那是一个壮观的扣篮，因为我不仅仅是把手伸过篮筐，我带着双脚飞越了篮筐，升到了篮板上方，然后直接把球砸了进去。我的整个身体都在篮筐之上。
Wow.
哇。
And stayed inbounds the whole time.
而且全程都在界内。
Mary Conway, talking with our own Nancy Updike.
玛丽·康威，正在与我们的南希·厄普代克交谈。
[MUSIC - "OH VERY YOUNG" BY CAT STEVENS]
[音乐 - 卡特·史蒂文斯的《噢，非常年轻》]
You know, we were going to play the Cat Stevens here as a joke, but it sounds really good. [LAUGHS] You know, because she mentions Cat Stevens in the piece. We don't have time to actually play it, because we have another appointment. And our appointment is with--
你知道，我们本来打算拿卡特·史蒂文斯的这首歌开个玩笑，但听起来真的不错。[笑声] 因为她在文章中提到了卡特·史蒂文斯。我们没时间真的播放它，因为我们还有另一个预约。而我们的预约对象是——
[MUSIC - "SHOOT PASS SLAM" BY SHAQUILLE O'NEAL]
[音乐 - 沙奎尔·奥尼尔的《投篮、传球、扣篮》]
This is a rap song by Shaquille O'Neal of the Orlando Magic, part of our continuing survey over the course of this radio program of rap stars, basketball stars.
这是一首由奥兰多魔术队的沙奎尔·奥尼尔演唱的饶舌歌曲，这是我们在本广播节目中对说唱明星和篮球明星持续调查的一部分。
Act Four, Basketball and Commerce. OK, sure, Michael Jordan has his multimillion dollar Nike and Gatorade endorsements. Dennis Rodman has a national bestselling book, a McDonald's deal. In contrast, the Scottie Pippen Dodge store on Western Avenue in Chicago is, I will argue, the most modest product endorsement in the NBA. It's a car dealership selling Intrepids and Neons and Dodge 4x4s. And right now, during the playoffs, the showrooms are filled with balloons and basketball players made out of balloons. The windows are painted with the words "Playoff Payoff." But mostly, it looks like any other Dodge dealership, a little rundown, with posters of Scottie and Bulls insignias here and there.
第四幕，篮球与商业。好吧，当然，迈克尔·乔丹有价值数百万美元的耐克和佳得乐代言。丹尼斯·罗德曼有一本全国畅销书和一份麦当劳的合约。相比之下，位于芝加哥西大街的斯科蒂·皮蓬道奇车行，我认为，是NBA中最朴实的代言产品。这是一家销售无畏者、霓虹和道奇四驱车的汽车经销商。现在，在季后赛期间，展厅里到处都是气球和用气球做成的篮球运动员。窗户上用油漆写着“季后赛回报”。但总体而言，它看起来和其他道奇车行没什么两样，有点破旧，到处贴着斯科蒂的海报和公牛队的标志。
I figured I should have a real Bulls fan with me when I visited, so I brought Beau O'Reilly, a Chicago playwright and musician and actor who's been on our program here a few times, and a Scottie Pippen fan. He pressed the owner of the dealership, Nick Farschi, for details about Pippen. But really, what's the guy going to say?
我想在访问时带上一位真正的公牛队球迷，所以我带上了博·奥莱利，他是芝加哥的一位剧作家、音乐家和演员，曾多次做客我们的节目，也是斯科蒂·皮蓬的粉丝。他向车行老板尼克·法尔奇追问关于皮蓬的细节。但说实话，这家伙能说什么呢？
Probably one of the nicest people you ever get to meet.
大概是你见过的最和善的人之一。
He seems publicly to be a very soft-spoken person, very kind of quiet person usually.
他公开表现出来的是一个说话非常温和的人，通常是一个非常安静的人。
That's exactly how he is. He's real soft-spoken. He hardly ever gets mad. And when he does get mad, then you'll know.
他就是那样。他说话真的很温和。他几乎从不生气。当他真的生气时，你就会知道了。
What does he drive?
他开什么车？
I think he owns a Porsche, and a Mercedes, and a Land Rover. Occasionally he drives a conversion van in the summertime.
我想他有一辆保时捷、一辆奔驰和一辆路虎。夏天的时候他偶尔会开一辆改装面包车。
Note that only the last of these, the conversion van, can actually be purchased at the Scottie Pippen Dodge store. When offered a chance to lie and push some Dodge product, owner Nick Farschi actually seemed to answer our questions honestly, to his credit. He admitted that Scottie only drops in once every couple months, that Scottie is paid a fee for the use of his name, and the business has increased a total of 10% or 15% since they put Scottie's name above the door. People do come in hoping to meet Scottie, or simply to get near the Scottie Pippen magic.
请注意，这些车中只有最后一种，即改装面包车，实际上可以在斯科蒂·皮蓬道奇车行买到。当有机会撒谎并推销道奇产品时，老板尼克·法尔奇竟然诚实地回答了我们的问题，这值得称赞。他承认斯科蒂每几个月才来一次，斯科蒂因使用他的名字而获得报酬，而且自他们把斯科蒂的名字挂在门上以来，业务量总共增加了10%到15%。人们进来确实是希望能见到斯科蒂，或者仅仅是想靠近斯科蒂·皮蓬的魔力。
And Nick Farschi said that, during 1994, when Scottie had a bad year on the court, walked out of a game with 1.8 seconds left, was arrested for carrying an illegal gun, was accused of domestic violence, well, sales did suffer.
尼克·法尔奇还说，在1994年，当斯科蒂在球场上表现不佳、在比赛还剩1.8秒时离场、因携带非法枪支被捕、被指控家庭暴力时，销售额确实受到了影响。
The business slowed down a little bit. People were nervous. It was almost like a disaster [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
生意确实放缓了一点。人们很紧张。那简直像是一场灾难。
Live by the celebrity endorsement, die by the celebrity endorsement. And there is, after all, something a little strange about buying a car from a dealership whose spokesman can sometimes be a bully on the basketball court. I mean, would you want the salesman to knock you around the way that Scottie hurls himself at, say, the New York Knicks. Mr. Farschi says this question misses the point.
因名人代言而生，也因名人代言而死。毕竟，从一家发言人有时在篮球场上表现得像个恶霸的车行买车，确实有点奇怪。我的意思是，你希望销售员像斯科蒂在球场上撞击纽约尼克斯队那样对待你吗？法尔奇先生说这个问题抓不住重点。
When people come in here, they're not in competition with Scottie, so that's-- When they come in here and buy a car from him, they're on Scottie's team.
当人们来到这里时，他们不是在和斯科蒂竞争，所以……当他们来到这里并从他那里买车时，他们是在斯科蒂的团队里。
And one way the Scottie Pippen Dodge store makes you feel like you are on Scottie's team is that they let you visit his private office, built specially on the premises, with glass windows looking out onto the showroom. Mr. Farschi was kind enough to open it up for Beau and I.
斯科蒂·皮蓬道奇车行让你感觉自己身处斯科蒂团队的一种方式是，他们让你参观他专门在店内建造的私人办公室，那里有可以看到展厅的玻璃窗。法尔奇先生很友好地为我和博打开了门。
The office is paneled with dark, expensive-looking wood. It's much more luxurious than Mr. Farschi's office, though it's clear from the moment you enter that no one does any work here. There are no papers, no clutter. On the wall are a few not-terribly significant mementos, a picture with the '93 Olympic Dream Team, a license plate with Scottie's number, 33, on it. There's a mini refrigerator, though Beau and I didn't have the nerve to look inside. Beau did take a peek at the private bathroom and saw Scottie's toilet. The most personal positions in the office are a picture of Scottie's dogs, and some amusements.
办公室镶嵌着深色、看起来很昂贵的木板。它比法尔奇先生的办公室豪华得多，尽管从你进入的那一刻起就很明显，没人在这里工作。没有文件，没有杂乱。墙上挂着一些意义不大的纪念品，一张与93年奥运梦之队的合影，一块印有斯科蒂号码33的车牌。还有一个迷你冰箱，虽然博和我没有胆量往里面看。博确实偷瞄了一眼私人卫生间，看到了斯科蒂的马桶。办公室里最私人的物品是斯科蒂宠物的照片，还有一些消遣品。
What's the parrot?
那只鹦鹉是什么？
That's just a toy. It's just a toy that he plays with when he's here. When he's here, usually he shoots hoops on the wall, and he practices.
那只是个玩具。那只是他在这里时玩的玩具。他在这里的时候，通常会对着墙投篮，进行练习。
He shoots like a little Nerf basketball?
他是用那种小型的Nerf篮球投篮吗？
Yeah.
是的。
But how does he play with the parrot? What does it do?
但他怎么玩那只鹦鹉？它有什么用？
It just repeats everything around that you say.
它只是重复你说的话。
Oh. [LAUGHS] Well, that's convenient. Can we get it to talk to us?
噢。[笑声] 嗯，那很方便。我们能让它和我们说话吗？
Sure.
当然。
Let's try it.
试一下。
Try it.
You push the button?
你按下按钮了吗？
Now just say hello.
现在说声你好。
Hello, here we are at the Scottie Pippen's store.
你好，我们现在在斯科蒂·皮蓬的车行。
Hello, here we are at Scottie Pippen-- Hello, here we are at Scottie Pippen.
你好，我们现在在斯科蒂·皮蓬——你好，我们现在在斯科蒂·皮蓬。
Ah, yep, yep. We're here in Scottie Pippen's office at the Scottie Pippen store.
啊，对，对。我们现在在斯科蒂·皮蓬车行的斯科蒂·皮蓬办公室里。
We're here in Scottie Pippen's office.
我们现在在斯科蒂·皮蓬的办公室里。
Ha, that's great.
哈，太棒了。
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
哈，哈，哈，哈。
I can see him playing with that all day. Well, here, we'll leave a message for Scottie.
我能想象他整天玩那个东西的样子。好了，我们给斯科蒂留个言。
Well, here, we'll leave a message for Scot--
好吧，我们给斯科蒂留个言——
Thanks Scottie, for letting us visit you here in your office here at the Scottie Pippen store.
谢谢你，斯科蒂，让我们在斯科蒂·皮蓬车行的办公室里参观。
Mr. Farschi guesses that if Scottie does well and the Bulls win the NBA Finals, it could mean as many as 15 or 20 extra Dodge vans, trucks, and cars sold from this store. If the Scottie Pippen Dodge store is the most understated Bulls-related business, in this, our fair city, with no TV ads, barely any Bulls hype, the most garish manifestation of the merchandising of basketball is downtown on Michigan Avenue, a combination shoe store and museum called Niketown.
法尔奇先生猜测，如果斯科蒂表现出色，公牛队赢得了NBA总冠军，那可能意味着这家车行能多卖出15到20辆道奇面包车、卡车和轿车。如果说斯科蒂·皮蓬道奇车行是我们这座美丽的城市中最不显眼的公牛队相关商业，没有电视广告，几乎没有任何公牛队的炒作，那么最花哨的篮球营销表现就在市中心的密歇根大道上，那是一家集鞋店和博物馆于一体的店，叫耐克城。
Niketown is the size of a small department store, reportedly grosses $2.5 million in sales each week. Inside, there are statues of athletes in midair, a 20-foot banner of Michael Jordan with a quote from William Blake underneath, display cases with sports memorabilia, slogans everywhere, like "Play to Win," "Total Body Conditioning," "Test Your Faith," on long banners hung in a mock socialist, WPA style. When you go inside Niketown, there are 18 separate pavilions, each with its own kind of sight and sound environment, like a real basketball court floor, and the sounds of squeaking sneakers on hardwood in the area that sells basketball stuff, the sound of tennis balls being hit in another area where they sell tennis stuff.
耐克城有一个小型百货商店那么大，据报道每周的销售额高达250万美元。里面有半空中的运动员雕像，迈克尔·乔丹的20英尺横幅，下面印着威廉·布莱克的名言，展示体育纪念品的陈列柜，到处都是口号，比如“为赢而战”、“全身调理”、“考验你的信念”，印在长横幅上，挂出了一种模拟社会主义、公共事业振兴署（WPA）的风格。当你走进耐克城，有18个独立的展区，每个展区都有自己独特的视觉和听觉环境，比如真正的篮球场地板，在销售篮球用品的区域能听到球鞋在硬木地板上的摩擦声，在销售网球用品的区域能听到网球被击打的声音。
As the writer, Andrew Levy, points out-- it's from a piece he wrote-- "The buying of goods invokes a sequence of events and images that make the purchase itself playful. Items move from the fourth-floor storeroom to the cashier stations through clear plastic tubes rimmed with green neon that suggest, as they are meant to, the cartoon future of the Jetsons. The direct purchase of goods is designed to appear to be an afterthought. The retail areas are cramped compared to the open atriums designed for the display of art and statuary. And the store's design requires every entering customer to be distracted by considerable aesthetics before reaching any locale where Nike items can actually be purchased. There are whimsical, anarchic features everywhere in Niketown. Tropical fish swim in a 22-foot, 1,000-gallon tank behind the hiking shoe display. A bank of nine television screens embedded beneath the floor nearby flashes images of glimmering swimming pools and waterfalls. It is seductive and very effective at creating sales."
正如作家安德鲁·列维在他写的一篇文章中指出的——“购买商品引发了一系列事件和图像，使购买行为本身变得具有游戏性。物品通过边缘镶有绿色霓虹灯的透明塑料管从四楼仓库移动到收银台，这让人联想到《杰森一家》中卡通式的未来。直接购买商品被设计成一种事后的感觉。与用于展示艺术品和雕像的开放式中庭相比，零售区显得拥挤不堪。店内的设计要求每一位进店的顾客在到达实际购买耐克产品的地点之前，必须被相当多的审美元素所分心。耐克城到处都是异想天开的无政府主义特色。热带鱼在远足鞋展示区后面一个22英尺、1000加仑的鱼缸里游动。附近地板下嵌入的一组九个电视屏幕闪烁着波光粼粼的游泳池和瀑布的图像。它极具诱惑力，在创造销售方面非常有效。”
[SINGING] I've been down to Niketown. I've been down to Niketown. I want to shake this angst I found when I was down in Niketown, down in Niketown. I felt so cyberpunk as I was walking down the hall. They got the [? Trial de Turin ?] in the toilet stall. I got the semiotic cross-training homesick blues. Hey buddy, is there somewhere quite where I can focus on some shoes? Now, what is that? Is that a talisman or a artifact of grammatology of some kind? Is that a subject, object, dislo-- Oh, it's a shoe? No, I'm sorry. I'm just so old that I get bewildered and stuff with all this gestalten you've got whizzing around here. Say, what-- Just, would you remind me what a shoe is again? Is it some kind of a-- Is it a phoneme? Is it a penumbra? Is that a-- Is that the shoe itself, or is that the idea of shoe? I nearly drowned in Niketown. I nearly drowned in Niketown. I just can't shake this angst I found when I was down in Niketown, down in Niketown.
[歌唱] 我去过耐克城。我去过耐克城。我想摆脱我在耐克城时感到的那种焦虑，在耐克城。当我走在走廊里时，我感到自己如此赛博朋克。他们在厕所隔间里放了都灵裹尸布。我有符号学交叉训练的思乡病。嘿，伙计，有什么地方能让我专心看鞋吗？那是什？那是护身符还是某种语法学的文物？那是主体，客体，解……噢，是鞋吗？不，我很抱歉。我老了，被这里飞速旋转的格式塔弄得晕头转向。说，什……就提醒我一下鞋子到底是什么？它是某种……它是音素吗？它是半影吗？那是……那是鞋本身，还是鞋的概念？我在耐克城差点淹死。我在耐克城差点淹死。我无法摆脱我在耐克城时感到的那种焦虑，在耐克城。
The song styling of Jewboy Cain, aka Mr. Jeff Dorchen.
这是犹太男孩凯恩，也就是杰夫·多琴先生的演唱风格。
Act Five, One More Dream.
第五幕，再做一个梦。
This dream was probably the biggest dream in my life as far as changing the way I was.
这个梦可能是我一生中改变我人生轨迹最大的一个梦。
We began this hour with dreams about the Bulls. And the most intense dream that anybody came to us with about the Bulls came from a guy named Brett Grossman. In his dream, Michael Jordan appears both as Brett's dead father and as Christ, healing and taking away pain. Brett says that he's had other dreams where Michael Jordan is crucified on a cross made of baseball bats.
我们在这一小时的节目开头谈到了关于公牛队的梦想。而关于公牛队，有人告诉我们最强烈的梦来自一个叫布雷特·格罗斯曼的人。在他的梦里，迈克尔·乔丹既是布雷特死去的父亲，也是基督，治愈并带走痛苦。布雷特说他做过其他的梦，梦见迈克尔·乔丹被钉在用棒球棒做成的十字架上。
But in this dream, the one that changed his life, there are kind of two big scenes. One is this traumatic event in Brett's life, where his father died when he was a kid, which he feels a lot of pain about. And the other is this scene where there's a huge coliseum, like a Roman coliseum, and in the middle there's a basketball court, and there's Michael Jordan on the court alone, trying to make a shot, trying to jump and lift off the ground.
但在这次改变他生活的梦中，有两个大场景。一个是布雷特生活中的创伤性事件，他小时候父亲去世，这让他感到非常痛苦。另一个场景是一个巨大的斗兽场，就像古罗马斗兽场一样，中间是一个篮球场，迈克尔·乔丹独自在场上，试图投篮，试图跳起离开地面。
And I'm feeling like Michael Jordan, something is grabbing him, pulling him down. And he's just, with all his strength, he's just jumping as high as he can. And it's like there's this pressure from below that's just ripping on him, pulling him down. And he's just suspended in there, as if his will and the pressure of the world and the gravity are at complete odds and smashing against each other, and his body is just ripping apart.
我觉得迈克尔·乔丹好像有什么东西在抓着他，把他往下拉。他只是用尽全力，尽其所能跳到最高。就好像下面有一种压力正在撕扯他，把他往下拉。他只是悬在那里，仿佛他的意志与世界的压力和引力完全对立，相互撞击，他的身体正在撕裂。
And the whole entire crowd erupts. Everyone's screaming, going crazy. But it's this maniacal-- It's like we're all watching someone being killed. And every time the ball dribbles, my pain becomes a little less, and Michael Jordan is just grimacing. And no one's going to help him, and I'm sitting there feeling like my pain is becoming less and then lessening. And there was all this pain that Michael Jordan had absorbed for me. And somehow, Michael Jordan, though, had, for this one second, basically neutralized a pain that I had felt my whole life, and this pain with my father, and a pain of just your existence, of being alone.
整个观众席都沸腾了。每个人都在尖叫，陷入疯狂。但这是一种疯狂的……就好像我们都在看着一个人被杀害。每当球运一下，我的痛苦就减轻一点，而迈克尔·乔丹只是在皱眉。没有人会去帮助他，我坐在那里感觉到我的痛苦正在减轻。所有迈克尔·乔丹为我吸收的痛苦。以某种方式，迈克尔·乔丹在这一秒钟里，基本上抵消了我一生中感受到的痛苦，这种与父亲相关的痛苦，还有那种仅仅是生存、孤独的痛苦。
And for this one second, I could feel it. It was the first time in my life that I ever-- and I woke up from the dream-- I ever realized that that's a possibility, that pain is something that you don't necessarily need to feel all the time to understand it.
就在这一秒，我能感觉到它。这是我一生中第一次——我从梦中醒来——我意识到这是可能的，痛苦并不一定是你为了理解它而必须一直感受的东西。
Why Michael Jordan? If you're going to have a dream like this, why Michael Jordan?
为什么是迈克尔·乔丹？如果你一定要做这样的梦，为什么是迈克尔·乔丹？
Because there's thing, there's Michael Jordan, and you see it in his eyes. And it happened during the Miami series of this year. I don't know how it is, but his eyes turn inward. He becomes very serious and solemn. And you feel that he is taking everyone on the team and just taking all their faults, all their backaches, all their problems, all their ego trips, and he's cushioning them for them. He's saying, "Look, I'm Michael Jordan, I'm going to win the game, you know that, stop. Just let it all loose and we're going to win the game."
因为有那样一种东西，有迈克尔·乔丹，你可以在他的眼睛里看到它。那发生在今年迈阿密系列赛期间。我不知道是怎么回事，但他的眼睛向内收缩了。他变得非常严肃和庄重。你感觉到他正在承担团队中的每个人，承载他们所有的过错、背痛、问题、自我膨胀，他在为他们缓冲。他说：“看，我是迈克尔·乔丹，我会赢得比赛，你知道的，别闹了。尽管放开去打，我们会赢得比赛。”
And I mean, I'll be at home watching the game on my chair, with my bottle of water, going crazy. And I see Michael's eyes and suddenly it's like, OK, I can relax, he's going to win it for me. And that feeling, it's crazy, but that feeling is something that I think you get from a god, and you get that from, whether false or not, you get that from a religion and an idol.
我的意思是，我会在家里坐在椅子上看着比赛，喝着水，陷入疯狂。我看着迈克尔的眼睛，突然间就像是，好了，我可以放松了，他会为我赢得比赛的。那种感觉，很疯狂，但我认为那种感觉是你从神那里得到的东西，无论它是真是假，你从宗教和偶像那里得到那种感觉。
That here's somebody who's going to solve my problems and heal my pain.
这里有人会解决我的问题，治愈我的痛苦。
Heal my pain and take away the indecision. There's nothing to worry about, because he's going to win the game.
治愈我的痛苦，消除犹豫。没什么好担心的，因为他会赢得比赛。
Well, hopefully, we Chicagoans will get to see that look in Michael Jordan's eyes again soon.
嗯，希望我们芝加哥人很快又能看到迈克尔·乔丹眼中的那种神情。
Our program was produced by Peter Clowney and myself, with Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike, and Dolores Wilber. Contributing editors, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin.
我们的节目由彼得·克洛尼和我本人制作，艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克和多洛雷斯·威尔伯参与制作。特约编辑：保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
If you would like a copy of this program, it is only $10. You can call us at WBEZ. That phone number, 312-832-3380, again, 312-832-3380.
如果您想要本节目的副本，仅需10美元。您可以致电WBEZ联系我们。电话号码是312-832-3380，再次重复，312-832-3380。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。